Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous etactivez la petite cloche !
Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Aujourd'hui c'est mercredi et le mercredi
c'est un moment de partage encore plus intense
dans notre communauté
des Épicurieuses et desÉpicurieux.
Puisque le mercredi,
je réponds à vos questions.
Allez c'est parti !
On commence avec unequestion d'Aline sur Twitter :
« Dis Jamy,
quel est le sujet le plus complexe
que tu ais eu à traiter?»
Sans réfléchir,
la matière.
Dès lors que l'on rentre
dans l'infiniment petit,
tout devient compliqué à expliquer.
Tout simplement parce que
vous le savez quand j'explique quelque chose
j'aime bien
conceptualiser.
J'aime bien utiliser des images.
Sauf que
quand on rentre dans un atome,
dans lesphénomènes qui se déroulent
à l'intérieur d'un atome :
la mécanique quantique
quand on commenceà parler de quarks et de gluons,
alors là,
ça devient très complexe parce que
ça ne correspondà rien de ce que l'on connaisse.
Donc c'est très très compliqué
et j'avoue que lorsque j'ai eu
à traiterce sujet,
eh bien,
j'ai un peu ramé.
« Dis Jamy,
qu'est-ce qu'une biotechnologie ? »
Alors en fait,
lesbiotechnologies
ce sont des technologies qui utilisent
le vivant
pour produire des choses.
Lemeilleur exemple
c'est le fromage.
Et c'est très certainement
la première biotechnologie qui a été
utilisée par l'Homme
tout simplement parce que
ce sont
des micro-organismes qui transforment
le laiten fromage.
Donc vous le voyez,
on fait appel
au vivant,
à des micro-organismes pour transformer
lelait en fromage.
« Dis Jamy,
depuis combien de temps portes-tu
tes fameuses lunettes si reconnaissables ? »
Eh bien je porte des lunettes depuis l'âge de 5 ans.
Mes toutes premières lunettes
étaient rondes.
J'ai eu beaucoup de lunettes rondes
mais c'est vrai que j'ai fait
quelque petites entorses
à cetterègle.
Et si vous fouillez un petit peu
dans les archives de la télé,
eh bien vous verrez que
danscertaines émissions
je porte des lunettes un peu moins rondes,
un peu plus carrées.
Mais sincèrement
jepréfère les lunettes rondes !
Une question de mayauxpaul8 sur Insta :
« Dis Jamy,
qu'est-ce qu'un trou noir ? »
Alors pour ceux
qui auraient un trou de mémoire
ou qui l'ignoraient,
comme vousPaul sûrement,
eh bien
j'ai réalisé une vidéo sur ce sujet
pendant le premier confinement.
Je l'ai publiée aux alentours
du 10 avril
si ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut.
Une questionde Volghan sur Youtube :
« Dis Jamy,
quelle est ta plus grande peur ? »
Alors je vais vous faire
unepetite confidence
mais surtout ne le répétez à personne.
J'ai peur des rats et des souris.
Mais
vraiment très peur !
Si là une souris passait à mes pieds,
je bondirais,
je me blottirais
dansles étagères.
Une autre peur que j'ai eue lors d'un tournage
mais une vraie peur aussi
c'estd'un animal un peu plus volumineux que la souris.
C'est un ours polaire !
Lors d'un tournage pour
« le Monde de Jamy »
au Svalbard,
un tournage sur
les animaux sauvages et les Hommes,
eh bien nousdevions filmer des ours polaires.
A un moment donné,
on voit un ours polaire.
Le réalisateurnous quitte avec le guide
qui était armé pour s'approcher de l'ours polaire.
Et je mesuis retrouvé,
nez à nez,
avec l'ours polaire à une trentaine de mètres.
J'avais avec moi l'ethnologue
Nicolas Dubreuil
qui m'a dit :
« A mon top, tu te lèves et tu pousses de grands cris ! ».
Car évidemment,
nosscooters étaient eux à une centaine de mètres
et on était incapable de partir en courant
pourremonter sur les scooters.
Heureusement
l'ours blanc nous a regardés,
tranquillement,
il a faitdemi-tour
et tout s'est très bien terminé.